oh hello you're probably thinking my
boyfriend said this was a superhero
movie surprise this is actually lucky
you a love story
well your worst enemy is after your best
girl it's time to be a superhero the
music I played a lot of those damsel in
distress ink we can't allow this
Deadpool nobody's getting hurt that guy
was already up there when I got here oh
that's good
hey youtubers it's Charlie so hopefully
you guys didn't have to sit through that
entire bachelor episode to watch this
hopefully you just saw this pop-up on
Twitter but they posted new Deadpool
footage mostly just focusing on the
copycat love story so the really weird
thing is they did this marketing
campaign where they posted it during the
first episode of The Bachelor and
hopefully you've never had to watch that
show or been forced to sit through it
but a little part of me was hoping that
it'd be like some twisted marketing
campaign and like this mini horse that
one of the chicks brought on the show
would eat one of the cast members then
Deadpool would kill all the cast during
the rose ceremony and ride off on the
mini horse thankfully they posted it
during the middle of the back half it's
like a two-hour episode so I was worried
that we had to watch all two hours of
The Bachelor but I do love the idea of a
Marvel version of the bachelor or
bachelorette like as long as they let
kitty pryde faze people's hearts out of
their chests instead of just kicking him
off the show like who wants to date Emma
Frost season where she just totally
messes with all the dudes minds that's a
good question let me know in the
comments if they did a Bachelorette or
bachelor show with Marvel characters who
would you want to see them bring on I
would love to see a season of The
Bachelorette with the Spider Queen where
she takes dudes into the fantasy suite
for sex but then afterwards she just
ends up eating him
Deadpool himself is a fairly self-aware
comic-book character so I actually I
think we're getting to the place where
we can see a funny show like that
superhero movies and TV shows haven't
gotten quite that self-aware yet but I
think I think we'll get there eventually
looking for love though let's count off
some of Deadpool's best relationships
starting with copycat siren who is
actually kind of like an angel on his
shoulder whose relationship was then
undermined by typhoid mary who was kind
of like the devil on the other shoulder
he ended up having sex with death
herself probably one of Deadpool's more
famous love stories outlaw who basically
runs around in the bikini he had a brief
romance with Black Widow kind of
one-sided Satana hellström daughter of
Satan Carmelita Camacho a little bit of
crossover with Luke Cage here and or
Scot just to show that he doesn't
discriminate this would be like if
Deadpool was Romancing the mini horse on
The Bachelor
so let me know in the comments who is
your favorite girlfriend of deadpool
over the years there's a lot more than
the ones i mentioned those are just some
of the bigger ones just in case you guys
haven't seen it i posted a whole bunch
of deadpool videos over the holidays you
can click here for my playlist and you
can click here to learn all about death
storm
on the flash season - thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you